university of chicago professor john
mearsheimer who do politicians lie to
well politicians lie basically to two
audiences one they lied to foreign
audiences other leaders and their
publics and two they lie to their own
people
who do they to whom do they tell the
truth
well they often tell the truth in fact
politicians or leaders
rarely lie uh to foreign audiences and
they rarely lie to their own people
uh and if you think about it it makes
sense if you lied all the time nobody
would believe you and if nobody believed
you it wouldn't make any sense to lie
lying is most effective when you don't
do it very often and therefore you're in
a position to catch people off guard
you put some examples in your book why
politicians why leaders lie
about
american presidents and some specific
examples about when they lie
yeah i have a whole slew of examples
my favorite example of what i call a
noble lie was the lie that president
kennedy told to end the cuban missile
crisis
kennedy had hoped to end the cuban
missile crisis by getting khrushchev to
simply withdraw the soviet missiles from
cuba but at the end of the crisis
khrushchev told him that he would only
remove the soviet missiles from cuba if
kennedy would remove the equivalent
missiles that we had
in turkey those were the jupiter
missiles now kennedy had no problem
removing those missiles in fact he had
told the pentagon to get the missiles
out of turkey before the cuban missile
crisis
but he understood full well that he
could not tell the american public and
he could not tell the europeans
especially the turks that he had agreed
to a deal where we would take the
jupiter missiles out of turkey so he in
effect told khrushchev that khrushchev
could say nothing about the deal
and if anyone in the american media
suspected a deal and asked him whether
there was a deal kennedy would have to
lie
but khrushchev should understand that
the deal was still on and of course the
media quickly picked up
the possibility that there was a deal
and asked kennedy and his lieutenants
about it and they lied and i think that
this was a smart lie to tell because
kennedy ended the cuban missile crisis
and given the gravity of the situation
at the time i think it was imperative
that he bring it to an end
without the possibility of war and he
did that and he felt that the only way
he could do it was by telling a lie
did fdr lie to get us into world war ii
he lied to try to get us into world war
ii in the
late summer of 1941 there was a naval
incident in the atlantic ocean involving
the uss grier which was a naval
a u.s navy surface ship and it was
involved
in an operation with a british aircraft
and they ran into a german submarine and
what roosevelt did was he told a series
of lies about the greer incident for the
purposes of getting us into world war ii
because at the time he was desperate to
get us into the war and he was having
great difficulty doing it because he was
dealing with isolationist america so he
told the lie to try and get us in but it
didn't work
it took pearl harbor to get us into the
war
professor mirsheimer when two world
leaders get behind closed doors do they
lie to each other hardly ever and the
main reason is that there's not a great
deal of trust to begin with when any two
world leaders get behind closed doors
states tend not to trust each other very
much
ronald reagan really hit the nail on the
head when he said trust but verify what
reagan was saying is you really can't
trust people you have to verify that
they're telling the truth
so it's really
going to be a highly unusual
circumstance where one leader
is in a position where he or she can
bamboozle another leader so you just
don't see much of that kind of line you
see some for sure but not much
when you see a president having a
special relationship with another world
leader does that tell you anything about
their
their
truth level
no i think it usually is a function of
strategic factors i mean winston
churchill and franklin d roosevelt had a
special relationship before and in fact
that special relationship was very
intense in the year before pearl harbor
because winston churchill wanted the
united states to get involved in world
war ii very much and franklin d
roosevelt himself wanted to get us into
the war so the two of them worked hand
in hand to do everything they could to
drag the united states into the war they
had a real special relationship
but they had no incentive to lie to each
other in fact all the incentives were to
work closely with one another
to get us into the war
politically why do leaders find it
easier to lie to their own public than
to
other international leaders it's
actually quite simple
it's easiest to lie
when there is trust between two people
or two groups
and in international politics there's
not much trust between any two states
one leader dealing with another leader
in most cases there's not much trust and
therefore it's kind of hard to lie
because the other side is distrustful
but when you're dealing with your own
public
in most cases publics tend to trust
their leaders they think that their
leaders are looking out for their own
good when we look at the president
united states we think that he's trying
to protect us that international
politics is a rough and tumble business
and our leader is doing his best to
maintain the security of our country so
there's a certain level of trust between
a public
and
its leadership and whenever there is
that element of trust
it means that
the possibility of telling a lie or
waging a deception campaign is very
great and of course we saw this in the
run-up to the iraq war
i think the american people by and large
trusted the bush administration this is
not to say that there weren't some
americans who distrusted president bush
but most americans trusted him and he
was therefore able to tell a handful of
lies that helped get us into that war
john mearsheimer we all often hear about
the special relationship between the us
and england
and
given the special status of that
relationship
are there lies told between these two
nations as well
tony blair bill clinton very close
george bush
tony blair very close i've looked very
carefully at the relationship between
tony blair and bill clinton and then
tony blair and george w bush and i know
a great deal about the bush blair
relationship because both of them were
involved
in dragging their countries into war
against iraq in march of
2003 and i think in both cases both the
case of tony blair and the case of
george w bush there is evidence that
they told a handful of lies to their
publics but there is no evidence that
they told lies to each other in fact
they worked hand in hand to drag the
united states and britain into that war
did you write this book before the
wikileaks episode started yes i uh began
on the book a long long time ago in fact
in 2003 and what happened was i got a
call
from a man named serge smaiman who was
then with the new york times and was
writing a piece for the week in review
section of the times on international
line and he and i had never met but he
said for some reason when he thought
about the subject my name popped into
his head why do you think that was i'm
not sure it's probably because i'm a
well-known realist and somebody who
believes in realpolitik is likely to
expect that states lie a lot and by the
way i thought when i first started the
research that i would find evidence of
leaders lying all the time and i was
actually quite shocked that that is not
the case the lies are told quite rarely
and when i used to go around the country
talking about this subject this is
before the book was published and i
would tell audiences that i can't find
much evidence of lying it was amazing
how cynical most people were they said
we can't believe that you're just not
looking hard enough
but the fact is there's not that much
evidence of lying but anyway he asked me
on the phone what my thoughts were on
the subject serge maimon did and i told
him i had never given any thought to the
subject and moreover i knew of no
literature on it so i asked him to tell
me what he was thinking and i would just
bounce off his ideas which is what we
did for about an hour we had a very
fruitful conversation i made a short
memo for the record and then a few
months later somebody asked me to give a
talk at mit and i decided to talk on
this subject and lo and behold a few
years later i ended up with this book
would this be a different book if you
wrote it after wikileaks no in fact i've
looked quite carefully
at a lot of the wikileaks documents and
stories about wikileaks that have come
out over the past year and a half and i
think that what you see with the
wikileaks documents is pretty much
in sync with what i say in the book you
don't see a lot of evidence of lying in
fact
it seems to me from the wikileaks
documents that leaders are quite blunt
with each other behind closed doors this
is not to say you don't see evidence of
line but to the extent that you do see
evidence of wine it's leaders lying to
their own country more often than lying
to each other and that of course is
consistent with what is probably the
main theme in the book
professor mirsheimer what a how do you
compare the us to other countries when
it comes to the issue of lying i think
that you will find more evidence of the
united states line than most other
countries
this is in part due to the fact that the
united states is a democracy
one should expect to find more line in
democracies than in authoritarian states
well for the simple reason that
democratic leaders are accountable to
their publics they have to explain to
their publics why they're doing x y or z
so anytime a democratic leader pursues
an unpopular policy
he or she is going to be tempted to tell
a lie to get the public to go along with
that unpopular policy that the leader
thinks is nevertheless a smart policy if
you're a dictator you don't really have
to worry very much about what your
public thinks about a particular policy
you can pretty much do what you want so
the incentives to lie are going to be
greater in a democracy than a
non-democracy also in the american case
because we have a penchant for fighting
wars of choice in distant places
presidents are going to have to do a lot
of heavy lifting to get the american
people to buy on to these enterprises
this is why president bush had to go to
great lengths to convince the american
people to do iraq that's why president
johnson had to
lie about the gulf of tonkin incident in
august 1964 to get the american people
and in particular the american congress
to buy on to the vietnam war and it's
why as we talked about earlier in the
conversation president roosevelt had to
tell why about the greer incident in the
summer of 41 to get isolationist america
into world war ii the american people
are not that enthusiastic about fighting
wars their leaders tend to be much more
enthusiastic and therefore there's going
to be a serious temptation to deceive
is it dangerous for presidents to lie to
congress
there's a potential danger for sure
first of all one can tell a story where
it makes good strategic sense for a
president who believes he has
a smart policy
to tell a lie to congress or to the
american people
and if he proves to be correct then
that's a smart lie
but often what happens in these cases is
that the reason that the president has
to lie is because the policy is not a
very smart one and it's actually the
people or the congress who are resisting
the president who have the better side
of the story
if you think about the iraq war
president bush thought he had the better
side of the story he thought that he
could deceive the american people and in
the end he would be proved right
but he was not proved right the iraq war
turned out to be a disaster and it even
had negative effects for the war in
afghanistan it was an ill-conceived
scheme
so all that resistance that existed in
congress and existed in the american
body politic was basically correct all
the people who opposed the war were
smart and president bush and his
lieutenants were wrong i want to be very
clear here i do not think that president
bush and his lieutenants lied for
selfish reasons they lied and they took
the united states into the war in iraq
because they thought it was in the
american national interest they thought
they were doing good for america but the
fact is they blew it
they didn't pursue a smart policy and
the naysayers
had the stronger hand to play and it's
just too bad that they didn't carry the
day in 1976 jimmy carter's campaign i
will never lie to you was one of the
lines he used did he live up to that
promise no he told
at least one lie that i know of and that
is uh when
it became clear
that the iran rescue mission was going
to be exposed he had jodie powell who
was his press secretary
lie
to the newsman who
smelled that this operation was about to
take place and i think in that case
president carter and jody powell did the
right thing i'm sure none of them felt
good about it
i mean
what's very interesting about lying as a
form of deception
is that if you think about it we engage
in deception all the time in our daily
lives
what we call it is spinning right when
you ask president obama how is the
american economy today he spins he tells
you all the positive news he downplays
or omits the negative news when a boy
meets a girl the boy wants to date that
girl that boy goes to great lengths to
portray himself in the most positive
light he's spinning
deception is part of the warp and woof
of daily life
but
but lying is a special form of deception
and most people in our society the vast
majority of people in our society would
recoil at being called a liar there's
something really terrible about lying
as a result of that i don't think that
leaders who lie to their people or
leaders who lie to other leaders feel
good about it there may be a few
exceptions and adolf hitler for example
is not going to care one way or the
other but someone like a dwight
eisenhower i think even a john f kennedy
was very very reluctant to lie for i
think moral reasons
it's just
it's a form of behavior that's actually
quite detestable but the fact is that
when you're dealing with international
politics
and if the security of your country is
on the line
you will not hesitate to lie not because
you're an evil person but because you do
what you have to do to protect your
country and that's really what i'm
trying to get at in this book are there
examples in the book of leaders lying
for personal reasons or for not national
security reasons no
i made it very clear in the front of the
book that i was not going to consider
those sorts of cases there are certainly
lots of them but
i left them out
i have been on a few
radio and tv shows where president
clinton lying about the
monica lewinsky affair has come up and
people
have asked me how i think about that and
i say that that's a case of a leader
lying basically to save his own skin and
that doesn't fit the category of lies
that i'm looking at here i'm looking at
what i call strategic lies which are
lies that leaders tell for what they
think is the national interest
one more example of a lie told on an
international level
i think a good example of a lie that
backfired involved nikita khrushchev
most young americans would be shocked to
know that in 1957 the soviet union was
the first country to number one put a
ballistic missile
in the air and number two the first
country to put a satellite in outer
space
but after launching their first uh
intercontinental ballistic missile
the soviets and here we're talking
mainly about nikita khrushchev who was
their leader at the time
lied to the american people and lied to
the american leadership and tried to
give us the impression
that there was a missile gap that they
had this huge advantage in missiles over
the united states in fact they did not
have a huge advantage in missiles we
couldn't tell what the balance of power
was regarding missiles because we didn't
have overhead satellites at the time
that could look down on the soviet union
and count their missiles so when they
told us that they had lots of missiles
most people assumed that that was true
of course they didn't have an advantage
in missiles but what it did was it
spurred us to build many missiles
and therefore
when president kennedy came to office in
1961 thinking there was a missile gap in
favor of the soviet union what we
discovered is it was that there was a
missile gap it's just that it favored us
and it favored us because they had been
lying and really didn't have that many
missiles and we of course in response to
their lies had built this rather large
arsenal of missiles
so that's a case of a lie that backfired
and there are i'm sad to say quite a few
cases were lies actually backfire
even on american presidents professor
mearsheimer what's your role here at the
university of chicago i'm a professor in
the political science department i've
actually been here for 28 years it's
been my only
academic job which is very unusual for
people of my age cohort most of my
colleagues have had two or three jobs
but i've only been at the university of
chicago
since my starting days as an assistant
professor back in 1982. what courses are
you teaching currently oh i teach a
course uh on great power politics
i teach a course on liberalism in
american foreign policy
and i actually taught for the first time
this past quarter a course on zionism in
palestine because i've gotten very
interested in the
israeli-palestinian conflict and very
interested in the history of zionism
what was the reaction to your last book
the israel lobby
well as i'm sure you know the
reaction here in the united states was
loud and almost overwhelmingly negative
in the mainstream press
i don't think that we've got a single
positive review in the united states
the most positive review we got was in
israel
and haaretz which is more or less the
new york times of israel
covered the
book
in three separate pieces including one
major review by daniel levy and all
three of the pieces and horror rats were
positive so we got a much better
we got much better treatment in israel
than in the united states why do you
think that is
i think it's almost impossible in the
united states
to
criticize israel or to criticize the u.s
israeli relationship in the mainstream
media
and if you do it
you'll pay a real price
i think israelis are much more
comfortable about themselves and much
more aware of their foibles
and it's a much more
open and free society
when it comes to talking about israel in
the united states it's really quite
amazing the extent to which israel
is a taboo subject here in the united
states why
well my view is that
the
strongest
supporters of
israel here in the united states
want
israel and the united states to have a
special relationship
they want the united states to give
israel large amounts of material and
diplomatic assistance and they want us
to give that assistance uh unreservedly
in other words without qualification we
just give it to them no matter what they
do this is what makes this relationship
so special so we have this large
interest group we call it the israel
lobby that has worked overtime for
decades now to put the united states in
a position
where it
supports israel unconditionally
now if you have an open debate where
israel is criticized for pursuing
foolish policies or israel is criticized
in ways that make it clear that american
and israeli interests are sometimes at
odds with each other then you begin to
question the special relationship right
you begin to say why are we supporting
israel in an unqualified way when the
interests of the two countries are at
odds
so the lobby does not want people like
john mearsheim and steve walt saying
that israel and the united states often
have different interests
because that might undermine the special
relationship
instead what the lobby wants is for
everyone to sort of be on the same page
and say that israel is an indispensable
ally and there's virtually nothing that
israel ever does that is wrong and
therefore the united states should
support israel and the argument that
steve and i make in the book is that
from israel's point of view this is
actually a foolish policy certainly a
foolish policy from america's point of
view but israel we argue is a normal
country like every other country in the
world israel sometimes pursues smart
policies and sometimes it pursues
foolish policies we have never seen a
country in the history of the world that
got it right every time
so our view is that when israel gets it
wrong we ought to be able to criticize
israel just like we criticize the united
states when it gets it wrong but the
special relationship prohibits you from
doing that
and to maintain that rather unusual
relationship which again is not healthy
for the united
that there's no st
of israel and this is i think what
explains in good part why there's hardly
any criticism of israel in the
mainstream media was there any spinning
or lying in 1948 when harry truman
recognized
israel
no i mean
there was significant pressure brought
to bear on harry truman this is well
documented to recognize
israel immediately and to help
get the united nations general assembly
accept
the partition of palestine which would
include a jewish state and a palestinian
state so truman played a key role there
but he was not lying or spinning in that
case the real line and spinning that
took place at that point in time had to
do with what
the zionists and then shortly thereafter
the israelis did to the palestinians to
create the state of israel
the fact is that the land
that is today israel was once filled
with many more palestinians than jews
and in 1948 the israelis had to
ethnically cleanse the palestinians to
create a jewish state that was about 80
percent jewish and 20 palestinian and as
you could imagine the israelis did not
want the world especially the americans
to know that they had engaged in ethnic
cleansing so they invented a series of
myths about what happened that made it
look like the palestinians were
responsible for their own demise and not
the israelis themselves but this was not
true john mearsheimer why leaders lie
was this
a fun book to write yes it was a very uh
very much a fun book to write in large
part because i didn't know much about
the subject
and i was sort of feeling my way around
in the dark and i learned a lot in the
process and i ended up surprising myself
as i said before i actually thought i
was going to end up telling a very
different story which is that there's
lots of line in international politics
leaders lie to each other all the time
but i found that the opposite was the
case there's not much lying in
international politics and i was even
more surprised to find out that leaders
lie more often to their own people than
they do to
foreign audiences so i think learning
new things is really kind of exciting
and fun and what this academic
enterprise is supposed to be all about
john mearsheimer is the author of why
leaders lie the truth about lying in
international politics also a professor
here at the university of chicago where
book tv is on location thank you for
being with us my pleasure
we asked what are you reading this
summer here's what you had to say